the West African Regional block Echo was
has condemned the decision of niger's
military rulers to prosecute the deposed
president for treason they're calling it
yet another provocation Muhammad bazum
was ousted and detained after the
military took Power by force last month
the un's called the developments very
worrying Markham Webb's monitoring
developments forest in Senegal's capital
Dakar Echo was the West African Regional
black also saying that they're shocked
by the decision
put out a statement just a short while
ago and said that it had learned with
stupid faction about the attempts by the
military authorities in Niger in Niger
to oust to charge recently ousted
president Muhammad
Muhammad bazoom they also
excuse me
they also said that they condemned the
action uh which uh they said
contradicted the recent reports uh that
uh the military authorities were willing
to cooperate to bring a peaceful return
to constitutional Rule and this comes uh
at a time uh when people are waiting to
find out if ecowas will indeed proceed
uh with its uh threat to to launch a
military intervention just last week
Echo echoas heads of state met in
Nigeria and ordered their military
commanders to prepare a standby Force
we're waiting for military Chiefs of the
region to meet sometime in the coming
week to further discuss that deployment
now we've just heard in the last few
minutes as you mentioned that the United
Nations had said it was a concerned
about these attempts to charge for zoom
and then we've also just heard from the
U.S state Department which has also been
critical of the move Malcolm you just
mentioned to us about the the standby
armed forces the deck was had put in
place and they had activated they said
that the time of course that diplomacy
was still an option do we know what the
options are for ecowas now
who Echo uses repeatedly said that it
would be open to diplomacy and open to
talks to return Niger to what it's
called constitutional Rule and to uh to
restore the democratically uh elected
president but it's also proceeding uh
appears to be proceeding with the
military option uh Cote d'Ivoire has
said it would contribute to Battalion of
850 troops to uh to an intervention
Force Senegal where we are and also
Benin would be expected to contribute
troops although we're still waiting for
the numbers now in 2017 ecowas
intervened in Gambia that was a
relatively simple military operation
compared to the possibility of this one
in that case Gambia is an enclave pretty
much of of Senegal and it took about a
month to prepare that operation so it's
expected to take at least as long to
prepare a military force that could
it's Malcolm Webb talking to us from
senegalscapital.com Malcolm thank you
very much indeed
well while there have been protests in
favor of the democratically elected
president who's now in detention there's
also support for the coup leaders
if there was high treason he is the one
who committed the biggest betrayal you
really can't spare him the military have
seen it all and there really has to be
Justice
what we are going through is not a Witch
Hunt because when you look at the Army
let's face it it's not all holy but they
are obliged to work together and should
do so for the good of Niger and a bright
future for the country well there's a
lot of uncertainty about President
bazoom's fate his Regional Powers push
for his release Ahmad Idris explains
from the Nigerian tunnel katsina near
the border with Niger
a lot of observers are confused as to
what is going on in Niger simply because
most of the calls and meetings between
President Mohammed bazoom and foreign
leaders at the military Junta is talking
about were sanctioned by the military
itself in Niger take for example the
meeting between the president of Chad
Muhammad Idris Debbie in the early days
of the coup when he was sent here by the
uh when he was sent to Indonesia by the
economic community of West African
states that was sanctioned by the
military and they met with the military
as well as president bazon himself the
other callers or the other people who
called president Mohammed bazoom include
the United Nations Secretary General
Antonio Gutierrez the president of
France as well as the secretary of state
of the United States of America so a lot
of people think that this could be a
power game being played by the military
in Niger Republic to strengthen their
hands so that whatever negotiation that
is about to happen will give them an age
so that they can also so use president
bazoom as a bargaining team we've seen
this play out in previous military coups
in the region in Mali in Burkina Faso as
well as Guinea so people are wondering
what is going to happen next right now
we understand that African Union has
also met and will decide on what next
line of action after the exploration of
its deadline to the coup leaders in
Niger also with the rising cases of
attacks in Niger on Sunday there was an
attack on a military base that killed
seven people there are concerns that
people in Nigeria will be wondering what
the military is doing about it because
that's one of the reasons why they said
they have intervened to take control of
government from Muhammad bazum Ahmed
Idris Al Jazeera katsina Nigeria